House Oversight Committee members will
decide this morning whether to subpoena
senior Trump administration officials
over a whistleblowers claim the issue is
top-level security clearances including
those for the president's daughter
Ivanka and her husband Jared Kushner who
are both presidential advisers a
longtime White House official says there
are quote grave security risks in the
administration's process for security
clearance applications Paula Reid is at
the White House with the story Paula
good morning good morning John that
whistleblowers name is Trisha newbould
she told lawmakers last month that over
the past two years the security
clearance application process has not
been handled in the best interest of
national security she alleges that
senior officials routinely ignore red
flags and grant staffers access to
classified information one day he said I
would have come down and I want to have
peace in the Middle East and I want to
do criminal justice reform and I want to
do all these wonderful things and his
life became extremely complex President
Trump praised Jared Kushner shortly
after news that Congress might subpoena
details surrounding his security
clearance Kushner dodged questions about
it in a rare interview last night I've
been accused of all different types of
things and all of those things have
turned out to be false I disclosed all
my holdings to the office of government
ethics and what I did with that is they
told me what to device what to keep what
was to follow the president's daughter
and son-in-law are among several
prominent White House officials targeted
by the House Oversight Committee as it
probes irregularities in the security
clearance process Tricia newbould has
worked in the White House for the past
18 years new bolt told lawmakers she and
other career staffers denied security
clearances for approximately 25 Trump
administration officials only to have
those recommendations overturned the 25
people were not named in the memo of new
bolts testimony released Monday by
Oversight Chairman Elijah Cummings now
the things that she has told us are
shocking to the conscience the testimony
did reveal that staff denied the
security clearance requests of
current senior White House officials who
had disqualifying factors including
foreign influence and outside activities
but those concerns were overruled by
senior officials in a statement
Republican jim jordan accused democrats
of releasing cherry-picked excerpts from
new bolds interview noting her 25
examples include non political officials
such as a government custodian the White
House has not responded to these
allegations but new bold who has
dwarfism alleges her superiors
retaliated against her which she raised
these concerns including taking
essential files and putting them high up
out of her reach Gail all right thank
you very much Paula